[Musique]
un monde dans lequel on avait réussi à
faire tenir la planète sur une dizaine
d'heures de vol les richesses mondiales
dans une dizaine de portefeuille
on est issu demande quelle est la
vitesse du son
puis a frappé un mur j'ai un
microscopique
[Musique]
un bel emplacement pour nous présenter
ce substitut de traditionnel
rassemblement festif pour la fête
nationale les célébrations donc y
asseoir meriem se déroulait à la télé ce
mode vidéo vous aviez les yeux rivés au
moins sur quatre écrans portables
je paie pas la seule clairement hier
soir vous avez dit un substitut de
soirée de fête nationale mais vraiment
on été gâtés hier soir deux heures
trente de belles télévision une fête
nationale bien sûr qu'ils n'étaient pas
sous le mot d'ordre des grands
rassemblements comme on les a connus
depuis les dernières décennies
mais d'emblée la soirée a commencé sur
des images d'archivés on a pu se
remémorer ces grands moments là et puis
vous l'avez vu il ya un instant fred
pellerin a ouvert le bal avec vraiment
une réflexion sur ce monde nouveau qu'on
est en train de vivre collectivement et
c'était ça le mode horde le fil
conducteur tout au cours de la soirée
fait pèlerin nous inviter à réfléchir et
je peux même certaines que plusieurs
téléspectateurs qui ont versé quelques
larmes et on a eu droit à de grands
moments tout au cours de cette soirée
animée par pierre lapointe ariane
moffatt
on le voit il n'y avait pas que des
vedettes le public était très présent
1re voisine surprenant qui a interprété
bobépine donc des choix de chansons
aussi très festive mais on a eu des
moments plus émouvant avec plusieurs
balades avec comme je disais tout à
l'heure cette idée de changer le monde
le choix des chansons a été fait en ce
sens là le monde est fou le blues à
métropole le temps
le début d'un temps nouveau donc la
fibre nationale vibrer très fort et
diane dufresne a été le grand moment de
cette soirée la diane dufresne
accompagné de trois orchestres et et
majestueuse
[Musique]
et il ya eu d'autres moments très
touchants très surprenant aussi un duo
pierre lapointe
hubert le noir ils se sont retrouvés sur
scène on a eu droit aussi à des passages
de l'extérieur à l'intérieur l'homme et
en salle à l'amphithéâtre cogeco mais on
a aussi été un peu partout à travers le
pays à travers la province à l'extérieur
on a donné une belle place aux jeunes
artistes le rappeur fou qui la fougue de
marine mythe de coeur de pirate une mise
en scène très créative on a demandé aux
artistes de se réinventer
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait sous la
houlette de jean-françois blais habitué
de ces grands-messes musicale télévisée
c'est lui qui réalise en direct de
l'univers donc une édition de la fête
nationale qui fera école
assurément et l'on va se laisser sur la
finale de la soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]